hey guys it's been a lot of like filming
and editing isn't going out of town but
we just recently learned
that aaron taylor johnson is going to be
playing craven the hunter
something you guys already know so just
want to pop on here super quick and give
some quick
thoughts or immediate reaction to the
news and especially because when i went
online
honestly i saw a lot of people kind of
dogging on the fact that aaron taylor
johnson's playing him
and i know some people were like oh i
wish it was jason mamow or keanu reeves
or something
like that right but i would say really
give the guy a chance i
i purse i don't know i actually don't
know how you feel about craving uh about
where the under and i don't know how you
feel better taylor johnson but
i i think aaron taylor johnson is
actually a very
underrated actor like do i prefer the
evan peters quicksilver
sure but i also think aaron taylor
johnson has done a lot of great work and
even in like the bigger films he's been
in things like kick-ass i think he's
done an amazing job and it's not like
craving the hunter type role but i think
he's great in there
and even re-watching godzilla a few
years
a few months ago i was like you know
people were like after brian cranston
the characters get kind of boring but on
re-watch
i think he gives a wonderfully nuanced
understated performance
and the guy also shows he knows how to
bulk the hell
up yeah you've seen him fluctuate in
just how massive he can get him too i
mean
personally i enjoy a choice like this
because then i'm thinking okay like
every take i saw on twitter was
this isn't who i would have cast and
then whether or not they're pleasantly
surprised or not pleasantly surprised
but for me i like this because i'm like
okay now i'm excited to see
how he transforms into this we know he
can do the eastern european
accent if necessary i think a lot of
people don't realize he's british
yeah like it blew my mind when i found
out
johnson's the point being is that he's
good with accents
i think absolutely uh so yeah i actually
think this is a really good casting
choice i think he can
develop the proper build for it even
looking at him and tenant the guy looks
like a beast
yeah with the beard and stuff you forget
that it took me a second be like look
is that aaron taylor johnson yeah so i
think this is really cool casting i'm
excited to see
what he does with it you know like i
feel like the sony verse with her
villains like morbius looks like it
belongs in the venomverse so i'm curious
to see what this movie will ultimately
turn
into craven the hunter was a villain
that i first learned about from watching
the spider-man animated series
uh i don't know if they'll go all out
with the accent and such
i mean they didn't do that with morbius
so i'm wondering if they're just gonna
americanize him up here uh which i hope
they do not
do but like i said i really wanted to
come here to be like guys give aaron
taylor johnson a chance i know there's a
lot of people who are
looking forward to him doing it i just
want to throw my two cents out there and
say i
have a lot of faith aaron taylor johnson
can pull this off he's got this
guys all right but the question goes to
you guys what do you guys think but
airtel johnson
be creative leave your thoughts down
below
video that's right that's what it looks
like on patreon
see the frame is always like cut here
but then boom
it's just a bunch of half-assed
[Music]
soundproofing